[Applause]
which means and we are also working
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but it's more like like we are trying to
[Music]
[Music]
it's sheriff's 95% of genes in human and
usually if you put some human gene into
Mouse it will probably work and if you
have a human big disease you will be
possible able to make a mouse having the
same problem
and there's a mouse Buddha which mimics
the disease in humans and all these mice
monastic and researcher like mechanisms
for these diseases and potential
treatments they are drink and I think
which means that like there's a
phenotype and genotype we have some
features which are influenced by our
genes so there's some gene gene code
with which influencing for example the
color of flowers or color of our pair of
eyes all those people are some different
different features which which are
influenced manage genes these are my
beliefs my liberation and Philip I think
is that we want to know all these all
these features though so we are doing
very of various tests from like behavior
you have this biochemistry and our image
images just some very complete medical
medical examination of this one is none
of my soul it's the Philip I think and
all the mums and also all so-called
knockout mice which knockout means that
we we remove or switch of one punch in
so so that it doesn't work anymore
and we are looking how it influenced the
phenotype and by by this the switching
of the gene by one by one we we want to
create mice gene function or an original
action and because there are twenty
twenty thousand genes in mice we
couldn't do it hello so we are part of a
bigger international consortium
consortium international most ethical
issue which involves nineteen research
institution all around the world and all
they have you could feel free
bridges for researchers the mouse
underworld some like a complicated set
of screens and they every screen has
some special special special protocol
how to do death and the special time
when Buddha is and for forty state away
me we get to be have something right at
the moment is something like internal
application that can show all the data
we have so far together with basic
statistical analysis it's something that
my colleague Fishman wrote and it's yeah
I know I go on Pilate about it's very
shiny it's something if you if you are
familiar with proven - or class so it's
something similar are and this this
earth who serves through researchers who
are familiar with our high schools to
society genes genes of interest and
Brook Brook of the data so would he be
her discovered so far no no cure for
cancer yet but an original baby finds
one she which which is linked with with
inherited my parents when you see see
very very badly then like mimic our
police found two genes that make
here across teams and almost be
incinerated if I ID see this many of
them wasn't previously known to some
Association i diseases so now I I will I
will
I'm going quickly through through some
some tests and I will start with a
little screens because I think everybody
wants to see Mouse going on sticks yeah
it's it's also an assessment of powers
and fine coordination movement we are
measuring the distance the loss is able
to go through the stick and it's like
open which is like Mouse and it's known
as mice don't like open spaces and they
tend tends to be near near walls so if
if the mouse is somehow strange when she
or he Brody maybe someone spent more
time in in the center and on the size we
are talking through camera and
threatened mouse movement and comparing
amount of time expense by the ball and
in the center
similarly like dark books most white
dark of space is that lighter or grip
SPECT where we are measuring
strength the mouse used to hold hold a
great for example there we have a
feelings screen and because you cannot
ask me so so we are doing by by
measuring electromagnetic activity over
the brains so so there since there's
some sound and with EEG we are measuring
if it has some response it's it's I
think it's pretty pretty cool in the
individual screen like this in in Mouse
eyes and if you are sometimes being
bullies do this are quite quite similar
they're beautiful example checking nice
memories in in such a big big box people
control and stable environment least
stable temperature and control oxygen
oxygen flows and we are referring cover
and it was oxygen consumption carbon
dioxide production and from from this
these things we are able to calculate
other other parameters like amount of
energy to any
on physical functions from these books
we have like such output it is in this
plot you can see you oxy oxygen
production Delta on the y axis this
position also shown expenses in its time
and we divide means my mouse and do not
especially this means the mouse hissed
night and the lightest basis is doing
today we are like unofficially changing
quite and and like this one by one it
looks quite messy average by by a strain
we can see that maybe if they found some
differences or not between between the
normal effects our Mice and mice ecology
in this in this in this problem which is
how the nose the eye blue is the draw
[Music]
the release but then there were some
some changing equipment source of
mobility
it's and here you can notice that the
curse like Cobra during the during the
light period so so it's because the
mouse mice are less likely to sleep
during the day so so it's if you sleep
you you don't breathe so much that when
you are running and exploring around and
now the fun begins because so now I will
be talking about micro CT imaging which
is which is my my my area of work now
and how does it work because you cannot
say Mouse just don't move for 10 minutes
people
so it's like of you so so we capture see
series of images of the mouse from
different directions of the 2000 angles
around their body and from this we can
reconstruct the date today I too like to
be cross-sections and also to the 3d 3d
model here you can see like soft tissues
and now
[Music]
will appear my bones so so I think yes
it's very cool because you don't you
know to do this thing so so over this
review my patient
we are doing quite open it quite
liberally on polish and we can like see
inside inside the box and one of our
oldest why we are doing that we wanna do
this we need to my plan is that we are
looking for a composition for ratio of
bones and we must fat mass this image I
think both are green we see this pink
and in the pipeline work it's defined
that you you don't want to calculate it
for us or for Tyler and you you have to
ring some some areas so here here you
have a cross-section of monks body like
cuz images the first one is somewhere in
the middle and the second one is around
shoulders
and well we have to remove remove
artifacts like border it's quite easy in
the first image do not you just choose
the biggest biggest mass in the image
but individual you want to enforce and
there are like together together with
the whole mass of the body so you just
choose the biggest thing you are young
if it is just woman in the green area
and to see see pale in your calculation
so how was it
don't be done before there was a lady
mrs. mom was like every day from morning
till evening sitting at a computer and
drawing these green areas so it was
really tedious tasks and many sheera
spent many many hours tried by the
computer so we were thinking we can
somehow help her to ultimately sink and
we realized that to be we are the only
ones that is problems how problem is
similar to microscopic images it's even
similar to finding cars images in the
cable competition so we said let's try
to do the same like they did and here we
use the unit architecture
the deep meaning live a little it's a
convolution of pollution Network here
you have like Johnson Central Park and
resolution like and I don't know if you
are these networks but just just just
have some idea of this the blue thing is
according to data and even some metrics
and you you loop matrix multiplication
[Music]
image in this picture picture picture
number which is represented by my in
this in these colors and lines in the
image but I have to say that these
businesses
you don't defined and before it's
computer land and then doing the
training its first you use a sample
semester and you are trying to optimize
the this matrix is so so that your your
predictions and your desired our so
civil service possible
behaving inundated by touch and it's a
planet Facebook it's inspired by my
washing machine my favorite touch it is
quite simple and people not being quite
successful we have the first right so
it's my current device free to some more
exciting things now now I'd like to talk
about some of our future plans we want
to do something similar for good
skeleton we are looking into shape of
bones different and we are trying to
automated asked for example the other
thing is all all spice has the same
shape or or we are looking from
differential I reckon say about the
substrate person wait a sec differences
and how can we do that we can measure
like Michael and of the skull and before
because sentimentalism Linda marks on
the skull in the images and compared
compared resulting shape but okay mr.
Dewey's my brother so be like try to
think about something something
different but if we compare the Raval
course count is Oscar volume or suffix
and it's this is more like image
processing unit basis the registration
group I thinking and Vicky there are use
mainly mainly for image processing and
he give us some preliminary results we
are comparing comparing the scowl result
each particular skull based on average
norrisville and first we we do two
iterative process correspond to to put
the horse hospital same orientation and
scale and we are calculating deformation
and here on these images the blue-collar
meats like magnitude of deformation
field the blue is 0 and ready some high
fiber you and you can see in the image
he scarcely burn so to wrap it up both
will do it moving me next accept
automation and money and telecoms and
chocolate maybe we need you well if you
if you are under STD if you like to
biology and if you like like this these
things you may keep in touch because we
have a higher rank next next years and I
have to see you see there so I'd like to
thank you autumn eyes
and possible or my colleagues when
Ashton who put it the whom who made
shiny hat to try to teach fortune who is
like micro city in general the money in
drama who made or the the innovation
which made the machine learning model a
possible and
[Music]
[Applause]
so should all parties have this time
computer science education or is it very
few specialists be great if Ohio
machinist um some education because
there are small they achieve a treat
quickly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah and we behave yourselves
can you really do it anyway I just yeah
[Music]
we finished actually
I don't know that I like my seat oh sure
there's some time plan I actually when
the near finish will be like looking out
Sheba my father being able to study like
combination of genes because there's
it's never-ending work I need to be
perfect finish them father
[Applause]